just want to bring you these latest  pictures which are coming in to us  from the capitol in ukraine kiev where  ukraine's president zielenski has posted  them on his telegram account that is of  course the defense secretary ben wallace  the ministry of defence has confirmed  that he has been in kiev to meet  president zielinski and his team  we know from president zielinski's  telegram account from for which we have  obtained an algorithmic translation i  should say  he writes weapons finances sanctions are  three things in which the uk has  consistently shown its leadership in  supporting ukraine we appreciate this  really real united work when words and  communication are constantly put into  action i am grateful to defence minister  ben wallace and his team for this visit  as well as to the united kingdom the  government and the prime minister for  their assistance so there we are defense  secretary ben wallace meeting president  zielinski in kiev